when you were young you're doing
stand-up Will Smith saw a tape of you
and signed you yeah he told me I
reminded him of him I mean I kind of our
first meeting you know I was rapping
telling jokes and I even I had a script
ready and I was like man this is the TV
show we should do together and I pitched
them a whole pilot right you know right
when I'm out he's like I'm in gave me a
TV deal a record deal put me in Men In
Black too he was truly a mentor when I
was 16 and always was a great example
man just just a solid dude so Nick the
big question is
when the whole thing goes down here you
are you're a stand-up comic when the
whole thing goes down with Chris Rock
and Wilson you're probably oh [__] I
love Chris Rock I love what the [__] do
I do and this is a real show business
problem it really is I mean what do you
do everybody's waking me up like yo you
see this I'm like what see what and you
know at first we all thought it was like
a skit or something or that's what we
were trying to figure out if it was real
but then obviously you know how it
rolled out they start you know showing
will cussing out you know keep my wife's
name out your [__] mouth like yo
that's he's not that's his best outfit
right there he should get an Oscar for
that
and I think once we realized what it was
it's like damn this is so unfortunate
because I was you know the first year
that you know will Packer was was the
producer we had a a black you know
production of you know will was winning
the Oscars the email performance it was
tough and then you know me I was
empathetic like man I Will's done
everything right his entire career
and you know letting your emotions get
the best of you in a moment like that is
his biggest moment I've you know I know
he wanted to he's been chasing chasing
that Oscar gold for a while and now you
know it's gonna be an asterisk because
you know of that moment and it's like it
was it was heartbreaking for me man and
then even for Chris man like even after
stand up there and have to go through
that like I I my heart just felt for the
both of them because really I mean if we
want to get into it and you know uh you
know the psychology of it all I mean I I
was just a glimpse into the black
experience the black male experience
because there's a lot of ego that goes
into what we all do and it's this thing
where it's like there's the bravado
there's this idea of like it's not you
know vulnerability has never been
something that we sit well with in our
community and you know that you saw two
vulnerable men and when when it gets
like that you know usually physicalities
erupt at some point
foreign